[Applause]
[Music]
this week's games are all about breaking
stuff whether it's the law a spaceship
or your very own mind sorry about that
last one but if you hit that subscribe
button you'll get new releases delivered
to you every week and you just might
find a fix in there now then here are
some of the biggest games launching this
week what's next from Gears of War
creator cliffy B lawbreakers this hero
shooter puts you on either the law or
the breakers side but both teams compete
and unique capture-the-flag turf war and
keep away game modes when it comes to
shooters you hear the words boots on the
ground way too much luckily law breakers
is all about total mobility letting you
sprint leave grapple and jetpack your
way around all the techno futuristic
Maps it's fast its frantic and you can
jump in on ps4 and PC on Tuesday August
8th if you can't wait until then to
check it out we've got plenty of
multiplayer gameplay over at GameSpot
the ps4 is also home to a spacey
platformer this week black hole complete
edition contains all the extra DLC from
the previous PC and Xbox one releases
coffee guy is pretty much the lowest man
on the totem pole on his ship but when
it gets swallowed by a black hole he'll
have to rise up and fix things you'll do
this by having him collect nanobots in
every level across a variety of
environments like caves jungles and
deserts you can get started on the 8th
and if the old steam reviews are any
indication you'll probably have more fun
playing this than watching Disney's
black hole he did things to me that sure
don't like to think you might know ninja
theory from the ps3 launch game Heavenly
Sword or the Studios reboot of Devil May
Cry but its newest project is hell blade
cinemas sacrifice you can expect the
usual action combat but this time it's
all influenced by Celtic and Norse
mythology and while past games have you
literally journeying somewhere hell
blade has you adventuring through
cinemas mind
which appears as an underworld full of
monsters from her own imagination you
can make the sacrifice yourself on ps4
and PC on Tuesday August 8th now let's
talk about a very real battle because
sudden strike 4 is set during world war
2 you'll step into the shoes of
historical figures like General Patton
as you take on 3 campaigns in over 20
missions but where many strategy games
focus on gathering resources and
building your defenses sudden strike 4
is all about the unique abilities of
your troops you can start strategizing
on PC on Friday the 11th with a ps4
release the following week and like any
good PC game mod support is included -
if you're not familiar with Knights wrap
strap in here's the pitch there's a
house full of young women and you have
to save them from intruders and you do
that by sitting behind a desk watching
them through security cameras and
hitting buttons this rerelease contains
all the original full motion video but
the gameplay has been totally rebuilt no
thanks to some missing source code a
physical version will be available for
ps4 on the 11th with digital versions
for ps4 and PC coming the following week
and those are some of the hottest games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with more games next Sunday